alors
l'or qui est très énergique
fou
je gagnais signé pierre en pierre à bien
voyager
je suis venu ici surtout pour pour
découvrir pour changer mon cas c'est mon
quotidien pour découvrir des gens pour
trouver d'expérience pour voir les beaux
paysages
vous pouvez poser les sacs se tient dix
jours
à
j'aimerais poser des sacs c'était
bizarre
qui est mal
soleil bonjour
gérard
j'ai souvent une fleur à l'oreille toute
l'année donc moi je vais l'appeler dame
nature semaine puisqu'elle est très
proche de la nature et c'est un vrai
petit bonheur et une vague de fraîcheur
la bienvenue à tout le monde vienne quoi
locaux la prélature je vous présente le
jeune est un
voilà on vérifie un petit coup il
consent objectivement on est à entre 12
et 13 kg est assez loin il fait doux
sous 12 bons kilos apparemment donc par
mois il est assez lourd quand j'ai pris
mes le strict minimum
voilà on va regarder ce que ça donne
le sac de couchage à l'extérieur du sac
c'est bien quand il fait beau
s'il se met à pleuvoir bon après on a un
poncho et tout mais c'est quand même moi
je préférerais voir le tapis de sol en
dessous et le sac de couchage ans ou
même si on doit mourir un peu
je suis attaché au confort des personnes
pas seulement au niveau du couchage
massif au haut niveau de la marche c'est
sicile 5e à l'équilibré s'il n'est pas
réglé la bonne hauteur ils vont être en
difficulté ils vont plus pouvoir
apprécier ce que j'ai envie de leur
faire apprécier c'est à dire la beauté
des paysages les plantes profiter
sereinement du canada j'ai oublié le
poids du sac
il ya une quinzaine de km il ya environ
500 m de dénivelé
c'est bon on y va allez zou
pour ceux qui n'avaient pas vu encore le
lac naturel gérardmer pas de barrages
pas de l'igas et c'est les glaces et qui
nous ont offert ce joyau il ya un peu
plus de dix mille ans pour notre balade
pour aujourd'hui sur cette petite buteur
face vous voyez un arbre un petit peu
particulier
c'est une tour en bois donc on va longer
une part que le lac jusqu'à la base et
on va monter vraiment pas rapidement
tout droit dans cette petite sur cette
petite vue de quoi aller
finie la rigolade là on change de monde
mon temps je monde
j'ai bon ils sont frais comme des
gardons donc on arrive sur le plateau on
va sans fil et un petit peu là il à
l'observatoire courrier tout à l'heure
depuis le lac
un petit peu fatigué quand j'avais
appuyé son estime et de portage du sac
d'audierne donc ça serait bien sentir
comment sait pas pourquoi il est si
l'eau en fait parce que j'ai pas mis de
choses vraiment inutile dans ce ca donc
le sac de couchage et le sac lui même
son lourd après
voilà j'ai la même chose que les autres
j'ai regardé ce qu'ils avaient dans leur
sac on a je ne sais pas la particularité
c'est que la courbe qui a été édifiée
par les scouts et solide mais ne
supporte pas un nombre de personnes
excessif donc on va faire deux groupes
pour pouvoir monter on peut pas monter
tous ensemble c'est pas du tout le
vertige et elle a l'air plutôt solide
mais j'essayais de faire bouger la tour
et pas le vertige donc tout va bien donc
qui saura les 4 janvier volontaires dont
j'avais donc c'est une tour pour vosgien
faut baisser la tête quand on monte à
près de grand
vous pourrez regarder déjà de petits tas
colossus hiver par rapport à tête
donc on voit bien l'église pour est
parti d'un centre du village de leur
père le clocher dégâts zone est déjà
bien à gauche
il faut réussir est très connu dans les
vosges trouve à retrouver donc stoppé
juste en face
dans les faits ce genre de photo vient
d'ailleurs jamais part au segment des
forêts
non
il agace
avoir pas dire des pistes est protégé
par l'ensemble du manteau forestier
donc pas de soucis il commence à être
dans les plus grands dans les plus
massifs la tête au moins et où va en
quoi c'est une des causes assez
importante de mortalité des arbres en
forêt c'est la prise au vent
alors quand il ya des grosses toutefois
en été mais surtout surtout en hiver
quand le pôle la neige mais dessus quoi
un peu de neige sur là où vous avez vu
là où tu es la tête des sapins quand
elle est bien grosse quoi ça peut
retenir énormément de neige donc
derrière un petit coup de vent et tous
les principaux axes qui domine en fin de
compte la végétation pour être soumis à
la casse quoi on se trouve qu'il est
vraiment génial plus il adore nous faire
partager toutes ses connaissances sur la
région basse et le but aussi je pense
et puis
non il est super bien parce qu'en plus
je dis rien ils essaient de nous faire
passer aussi le message qu'il faut aussi
randonnée par paix par plaisir en fait
et donc ça ça compte beaucoup dans sa
vision des choses et puis moi je partage
assez bien cette vision là aussi donc
bon
pour la qualité
je crois que la dame avec un t-shirt ou
violet je marquais plus son nom monique
moyenne à muret est là ok j'ai senti ce
matin d'un groupe que muriel était
peut-être un peu limite physiquement
elle s'est vite essoufflée quand on a
grimpé pour arriver à l'ère des
pique-niqué elle était souvent derrière
donc qu'elle va être vite fatigué par
rapport à nous que tu sais pas trop on
verra bien quoique c'est surtout le
portage qui qui fait que je suis un
petit peu à la traîne
et puis bon aussi certainement le manque
de l'endurance à ça c'est sûr maintenant
c'est vraiment la première journée donc
forcément d'un petit peu mal partout je
pense qu'après il faudra il faudra boire
on aura l'habitude je veux dire de
porter ce sera déjà un petit peu moins
moins dur le deuxième jour quoique je
pense que les muscles vont se réveiller
aussi donc c'est pas gagné
on a bien duré une bonne mise en jambe
on a bien mérité le prix moi ce que je
ne suis pas du matin mais à prendre du
poil de la bête
ça s'appelle le carvi faut le frotter
comme ça dans les doigts tu te mets
chauds dégageaient hambourg plus d'odeur
c'est luc harvey ont l'utilisent surtout
au niveau des graines
ce plan doit on va décoller un ça va
arriver avant la nuit c'est soit je suis
raisonnable fou quand même faut quand
même qu'on marque
la vallée du bouchot célèbre pour les
moules de bouchot bien évidemment
abo
l'important c'est de sauvegarder ses
articulations genou ans chez nous
surtout en stoppeur amortir par les buts
regarde une petite gâterie de la
montagne la forêt oxalis alors tiens
pour ceux qui connaissent pas les
prendre c'est lisse comme moi vous la
mâchouiller et puis au goût vous allez
me dire à quoi ça me fait penser
john a souri alors d'autres d'autres
avis le l'oseille très bien donc ça
lisse et le long de l'a produite aux
iphone cause
voilà c'est désaltérant c'est à dire
qu'on l'apprend la mâchouiller lagarde
en bouche c'est vraiment que de choses
qui vont sympa à voir en bouche quoi
désaltérant quand il fait des belles
journées comme ça allez zou je continue
un jour prétendre à tallinn autres
puisque nathalie va vous faire déguster
ces potions magiques avec ça vous pouvez
ça vous est requinqué c'est reparti pour
une marche de rupture derrière donc ceux
des vertus anti inflammatoires
oui c'est parfait pendant jeunes anti
grippal lanxade fébrifuge alors les
anciens disaient que ça faisait sortir
la maladie
voilà moi j'aime bien les plantes et
puis j'aime bien en faire profiter les
autres donc forcément je vous donnerai
la recette donc la fleur de sureau noir
est reconnaissable par rapport au sureau
rouge parce que les grappes qu'elles
sont en fleurs ou en fruit tombe comme
ça mon amie charlène charlène la poule c
le magnifique et très gentil et pourquoi
ça se conserve un an parce qu'en général
c'est un peu plus chaud bon là des
volontaires pour la cuisine cinq minutes
dans sa minute ou à ça peut attendre un
petit peu pas de souci ok on vous attend
on va faire un petit arcarde orties pour
commencer leur part alors quand on
cueille des sorties on prend juste
la sommité jeux d'argent non se sait pas
c'est pas bien méchant
en fait ça s'applique parce qu'elle est
petite aiguille qui explosent à tout
contact
je m'y attendais pas du tout je ne
connaissais pas grand choses dessus donc
j'apprends des choses alors il ya quand
même un truc pour pas se faire piquer
canton quand on accueille coin c'est
d'expirer ou ne pas respirer du tout à
ce moment-là vous ferez pas piqué fou
en apnée way ou expirés
si vous êtes fatigué pendant une
randonnée vous pouvez prendre une
feuille ou la replier vous presser un
petit peu ça c'est pour casser les
aiguilles et vous le mettez sous la dent
je vous garantis que vous qu'après au
point de vue vous retrouverez votre
énergie
voilà on a des armes donc en cap
ben j'ai dû escalader pour voir attrapé
du réseau parce qu'en fait on est en
contrebas là et on est complètement
isolé il ya on est coupé du moins
complaisant et demain matin ce qu'on
vous propose c'est de confier à vos
portes à ce qui évitera de les perdre
dans un premier temps que vous pourrez
bien sûr récupérer dès la soirée venu
beaucoup de gens qui m'appellent à
n'importe quel moment puisque je fais
soit de l'animation de soirées soit du
guidage de pêche
je vais passer mon diplôme et un mois et
bombe à la saison de pêche est bientôt
finie mais par contre l'animation de
soirées et aujourd'hui on m'a appelé
pour une soirée dans quinze jours hier
on m'a appelé pour une soirée il ya dans
un mois c'est des appels que je ne peux
pas manquer quoi puisque puisque c'est
mon gagne pas il ya quelques années
j'aurais réagi exactement comme jérôme
et je le comprends pour ça mais
maintenant c'est bon je suis lancé donc
lâché en vacances donc comme un portable
hp l'état n'y a aucun souci pour ça le
soir je peux allumé pour la famille et
la copine mais c'est le vacances ou
professionnels donc et pas de souci
c'est vrai que là à midi j'ai fait la
connerie de répondre
un coup de fil et ça m'a pas plu donc je
pense qu en autogestion je les utilise
juste sur l'appareil photo
ça fait des chouettes photos et ses
pratiques
donc je vais le garder mais je vais moto
gérer donc je te fais un gros bisou et
puis il ya bientôt la claquette
ciao je suis puni à 40 ans voilà ont
puni comme un enfant pas le droit de
téléphoner pendant la journée même chose
être remettre pour la journée en
espérant que je le retrouverai ce soir
je me suis surprise en fait d'oublier
que effectivement dans mes habitudes
j'ai besoin d'avoir un portable tout
pendant la poche pour me rassurer et ça
fait vraiment du bien de casser les
habitudes et et c'est une très bonne
initiative que pierre ben ce que puis on
nous a proposé c'est vraiment très bien
et je renouvelle l'opération demain là
non plus bas si vous
on peut parfaitement se nourrir avec des
orties avec les plantes qu'on trouve
dans la nature
et après on h tout ça et puis après on
m'offrait d'après votre goût
oui et sur la shoah recherche de plans
alors une berceuse wilshere fort en plus
ça se resserre de 2 200 tirs au but à
marjah mais la cuisine c'est vraiment
pas mon truc
il ya des 13 il ya des spécialistes de
la cuisine dans le groupe donc on va
profiter de leur savoir faire cette
semaine je suis chez moi pour manger
c'est soit des plats préparés
soit un sandwich fait sur le pouce à la
rage comme ça moi c'est beaucoup de
plats micro ondable deux minutes
micro-ondes tu perces le dessus et puis
tu enlèves après fitch et mange ça quoi
ça n'a aucun goût c'est ainsi pin encore
une fois moi la nourriture j'aime
beaucoup la manger j'aime pas la faire
mais c'est pas c'est pas une de mes
priorités dans la vie ça me gêne pas de
bien manger en fait je vous donne à
chacun une part de d'ortie mélange avec
les oignons et après c'est à vous à
votre goût parce que voilà les orties ce
même chose ça c'est à vous de rajouter
un peu de temps mais bon le peu de soja
un peu un peu plus ou moins de l'outarde
donc un vrai et puis vous goûterez
chacun puis vous verrez que ça change
selon qu'on rajoute un peu comme
saint-amand voilà j'y suis allé par
petites doses dès le début j'ai rajouté
après il n'a commis beaucoup qui ont
voilà c'est ça la différence mais après
ses goûts les couleurs quoi
effectivement le poivrier je le fais
depuis j'ai tourné alors ça ne marche
pas forcément je fais pas ça a été un
oubli de ma part mais c'est pour montrer
à quel point je n'utilise jamais de
pauvres y est par exemple si j'utilise
du poivre mais c'est pas dans un
poivrier c'est pas moi qui le qui le mou
quoi elle est déjà prêt c'est ça reflète
tout à fait mais mon expérience avec la
nourriture faut que ce soit tout près
faut que ce soit rapide
moi ce que je ne supporte pas dans la
nourriture dans le fait de faire la
cuisine c'est med +2 allez on va dire
dix minutes pour faire à manger
nathalie tu veux goûter j'ai préparé des
tartines pour les collègues on m'a fait
des tartares d'ortie il assuré aux
cailloux mais ouais je suis très
surprise par va par le goût ça dégage
ouais c'est vraiment agréable
globalement je suis je suis agréablement
surprise parce que j'imaginais pas du
tout
à voir cette ce goût en tartare dirty j
j'ai très peu l'habitude de cuisiner
avec des produits comme ça de la nature
va déjà se cuisinent pas énormément pour
commencer ensuite c'est vrai que j'ai
pas du tout l'habitude de cuisiner des
produits comme ça un petit peu
particulier
cueillie même la nature donc j'ai trouvé
ça super intéressant
ce soir on a attendu beaucoup pour
manger mais samassa m'a pas dérangé ne
m'a pas dérangé parce que je n'avais pas
faim pas énormément fin par contre j'ai
vu que les autres très fin ce soir en
attendant le repas
je sens bien là dans les muscles
j'adore marcher que marcher 20 bornes
s'il faut mais il serait portée c'est
vraiment pas montré que non que là c'est
sûr que j'ai un petit peu mangé les
premiers secours
comment savoir
tu vois je suis surpris qu'on dorme dans
des tipis je pensais qu'on allait
vraiment dormir dehors au mieux avec un
petit fait qu'on allait faire jeter mais
enfin je m'attendais vraiment à ce à
quoi dans les duvets bonjour à tous du
soleil pour ce lundi sur la lorraine les
nuages présents ce matin se désagrège
peu à peu et les éclaircies s'imposent
dans un ciel pas totalement bleu mais
presque
le motard français le matin
c'est agréable nuit tout s'est bien
passé un peu humide mais dans l'ensemble
tout va bien vous n'êtes pas un café
près les tartines sont en fait j'ai bien
dormi que penser d'une femme tuée bercé
par de petits ronds fleurs alors c'est
quoi qui reflète non excusez-moi mais
dans l'ensemble ça passe à ce qu'on m'a
dit ça à verser quelques personnes donc
c'est ce n'est pas cité à l'effort que
tu es riche sûr que ça râle après je
donc l'agent mais combien le contraste
entre le mythe et un peu nomade un peu
rustique quoi est au contraire un bond
par la chaleur c'est intéressant
envoyé sur les panneaux chalet ducharme
et en fait on sait pas du tout ça en
ordre à bibracte et on finira la semaine
samedi normalement on est encore les
neuf là haut